in this episode of my G UI tutorial
series we're creating a transition scene
system where we can fade in and out
automatically when changing scenes these
tutorials are part of a long series of
user interface tutorials for G and as
always you can grab the source files for
this and all of my GTO tutorials on my
patreon I'm working from the last
episode scene changing structure the
goal is to Overlay a transition
controller scene over the rest of the
nodes and animate a black background
first create a new new control scene
named transition controller with this
structure the color wct will have a
black background with an alpha setting
of zero set layout mode to Anchors and
anchor to full wct in the animation
player create a new animation called
fade in and create an animation track
for the color property of the color wct
node the animation length should be 1
second set the alpha to 255 or 100% on
the first frame and zero on the last
frame create another animation called
Fade Out and reverse the color settings
Rec created zero on the first frame and
100% on the last frame next add the
transition controller scene to your main
scene if you're working from your own
setup you want the transition controller
scene to be at the bottom of the scene
tree so it has a higher layer priority
meaning it is layered on top in the
transition controller scene add a script
set the class name to scene transition
controller and add two export variables
to reference our color node and
animation player node be sure to assign
those in the the inspector create a new
function transition with parameters for
the animation string and length of the
transition in seconds the function will
reference the animation player node and
call the fade animations we just created
for the length of the animation we're
adjusting the animation speed by
dividing the length of the animation 1
second by our desired length next we
adjust our game controller script that
handles our scene changing we need to
add new parameters to the three
functions a transition Boolean the
transition and animation string
transition out animation string and the
transition length I've also set defaults
so we don't have to set those every time
we call the function before we swap any
scenes we check if we want to transition
if true we run our transition animation
with our desired settings and await till
the animation is finished in our case
the scene should now be black and we can
swap our scenes after we run our scene
change code we run another transition to
fade in the scene remember to add these
changes to each function as well you
should now be able to fade in and Fade
Out when changing scenes you can also
create your own animations and run those
including shader-based transitions
[Music]